oh
what are you doing here though i was
just wondering if you would happen to
follow me
you speak of the god of animo barbados
he already disappeared from monsted a
long time ago
lila and anazuma's respective gods of
geo and electro are still present
but monstat has seen many a moon since
they last saw their own god
why do you wish to know about the god of
animal does it have something to do with
divalen
oh uh it's because god's
um just how is it that everyone sees
storm terror
i'm quite curious that said there's no
need to rush
i have not been back in a while it seems
there are a few who are
unhappy with my arrival
yes
uh
cool it
does this
try not to enjoy this too much
come a little closer
seems the dragon wasn't the only thing
affected by this change in the wind
now then you were saying someone had
told you about the dragon
is that so quite the scholar i must say
that lisa
she's not wrong the conflict has reached
this point
only because both sides have resorted to
the use of force
his hate however did not arise from the
people not making tribute to the four
winds
nor was it born from his own nature but
instead
came about as a product of his
degradation degradation
the black blood flowing through his
heart has been torturing him for years
that's what has allowed him to be led
astray by the lies of the abyss mage
they are from the abyss order an
organization comprised of non-human
beings
they despise mankind i don't know where
they come from
all i know is that they hold deep hatred
toward the human world
many hilly trolls out in the wild take
orders from them and act as their
weapons
before arriving here i too was like
devolent
cursed and left to waste but now
before us stands the symbol of monstat's
hero
the place from which monstat rose the
wind amongst the branches is good
i love the way it smells being here with
you beneath this great tree feels like
when the tear was purified earlier
like the poison is leaving my body
feels much better so how exactly did you
get poisoned
uh that would be because i tried to
communicate with divalen earlier but was
interrupted as a result not only did i
not manage to help divalent break his
curse
but instead was also infected my yes it
was you
so to make up for it you're coming with
me to the cathedral
the monster cathedral to do what exactly
to claim a certain holy liar to hamel